hey we need to tell the projectionists
their sound but no picture oh wow so
wait the one ring is supposed to control
everyone who wore the other rings right
we're told later that the race of men
were turned into the nah school but it
didn't affect the elves and dwarves at
all apparently Sauron put on his ring
and tried to control the dwarves and
elves by yelling go ring and all he got
was sparks flying out of his fingers
what the is Sauron reaching for just
kill the guy you have this huge mace for
killing reading and I don't expect I
should return in fact I mean not after
build those unnerving Proclamation
Gandalf apparently said dude you need to
smoke some weed
Bilbo then said kids I'll tell part two
of this story next year and I'll finally
finish it the year after that because
even short stories are best when told in
trilogies
[Music]
when you see Gandalf magically transport
like this don't you wonder why he
doesn't use magic more often in crucial
spots during the trilogy Gandalf should
probably know that that's not true
because Bilbo had no time to put it in
an envelope but he goes over to the
mantelpiece expecting to find it anyway
what's Frodo doing for the last 20
minutes after Bilbo disappeared looking
for Bilbo in places other than Bilbo's
house Gandalf sees the freaking Eye of
Sauron when he stupidly tries to touch
the ring but yet he still needs to do
research to figure out what the ring is
it doesn't he have more than enough
information at this point to give Frodo
a head start before the ring wraiths
show up this is the only time in the
movie where that non-school will just
straight-up murder a dude all he said
was who goes there and he gets snuffed
out this could have been the guy who
knew all things Baggins and they just
destroyed their best lead I guess farmer
maggot gave up or at the very least his
side did get off the wrong convenient
hiding trees convenient also this one of
the nine is terrible at his job isn't
the ring supposedly calling to Sauron I
mean why is he even sniffing if his nose
work he clearly would smell the hobbits
or the ring if the NAS Bowl can't detect
the ring two feet in front of their
faces why didn't Gandalf just find a
container for the ring that he could
magically seal at least lock and throw
away the key so no one could get into it
Frodo wouldn't be tempted to wear it and
no one could possibly detect it and the
road to Mordor becomes that much easier
then he falls for the old tossed
something to distract the bad guy trick
from every other movie ever it went from
day to night very fast here but maybe
that much time has really passed in this
case so if that's true as the ring
wraiths been chasing the hobbits for
several hours without making one bit of
headway and only now our merry and
pippin asking what the hell is going on
bad guy doesn't like water cliche Peter
Jackson tries to one-up em Knight and
Hitchcock by gnawing on a carrot during
his directors cameo if the ring can will
itself to land perfectly on Frodo's
finger than one of can it just will
itself to fly off into the air and roll
its happy way back to Mordor how did Sam
merry and pippin know Frodo was up here
they didn't call into Frodo when he
reappeared downstairs so were they just
running around crashing into every
closed door until they finally rained
into Frodo at all
they feel the presence of the ring drone
to the power of the one until it's
convenient for them not to be drawn to
it if you look really hard you can see
Tom Bombadil in the shop either you
don't care if Gandalf dies in which case
just kill him or you want to keep him
alive for some reason in which case
don't put him in a prison that basically
anyone would die in at the first
thunderstorm I know the hobbits are here
for comic relief for the most part at
least early on but damn nobody is
anywhere near that stupid to light a
fire on a tower at night when you're
hiding from Supernatural hunting
machines nobody also Strider says he's
just going to have a look around when he
leaves the hobbits where did he go and
how far away he didn't see the fire
immediately and start running back to
slap all the hobbits for starting one
and he didn't notice the nazgûl anywhere
while he was looking around after we've
seen them straight-up murder people for
asking who goes there the nos who will
finally find the hobbits and decide to
go into a slow attack formation so that
Strider can show up in time to save the
day
oh these bad guys are afraid of water
and fire Wow so earth is like the only
major element they're not afraid of
stabbed by a male you know the kind of
dissolved dramatically after you
identify it you know the weed is the
answer to everything I see elf horses
have turbo modes well we're only an hour
in but it's already clear that good ol
h2o is the real hero of middle-earth
Arwen has the ability to summon a
tsunami of water horses want a strangely
specific ability Aquila ex machina is
there really nothing that sörman can do
about the eagle isn't he a powerful
wizard doesn't he caused a Naville anch
from hundreds of miles away later in the
movie he spins Gandalf around and closes
doors with his mind but an Engel is just
too tall of an order
[Music]
so Elrond knows this is a ring of
supreme evil all the evil in the world
can be ended by throwing the ring in the
fire but he lets us hold or go without a
fight he could thrown him into the fire
and then ran out screaming oh no missile
door fell into the fire whatever will we
do oh the humanity you mean the axe you
just shattered while trying to destroy
the ring you should be the Fellowship of
the Ring roll credits oh wait where did
they get sausages did they make them
themselves out here in the wild or are
they carrying raw meat casings for 40
days without refrigeration and then
eating them these birds have no conclude
that that's where Gandalf decided to go
they flew past them they may have seen
them go run and hide but they weren't
around here Gandalf say where they were
gonna go next let the ring decide
how does Gimli not know about this or
Gandalf this obviously happened a long
time ago sure there's no internet or
phones but work should have traveled
faster than this
these hobbits over here on the left give
no indication whatsoever that a cave
troll is about to peek around the corner
why isn't Frodo his blade glowing right
now or all the orcs dead or right now
right now there's definitely some work -
close enough to cause that blade to glow
blue right
Gandalf said it was a four-day trip
through the mines but it takes the
fellowship like a couple of hours if
that to get to the other side dude this
movie is three hours couldn't you just
ask where Gandalf is right off the bat
why would the mirror show his friends
making troubled glances what can be
learned from that that I could have told
you that he will try to take the ring
you know of whom I speak I'd love to
tell you which person by name but I'm
afraid he'll hear this telepathic
communication that only you can hear
[Music]
terrible is that Dolan is that supposed
to mean oh now it's glowing again and
long before the orcs are even in view
the uruk-hai throws a shield at
aragorn's neck that has a neck sized
hole at the end of it Frodo screams and
stares at a drowning Sam for several
seconds before helping him jeez how deep
can a hobbit reach into the water from a
boat
welcome to Rivendell mr. Anderson spits
Qi boy I think there's more to this
habit it reads here maybe found the last
words of Joseph of Arimathea he who is
valiant and pure of spirit may find the
Holy Grail in the castle of